arm-based laptops have been available
for a few years now but they haven't
been very good and Samsung is trying to
change that with this new galaxy book s
and in this video I will tell you both
the good and the bad along with what
having a Snapdragon ARM chip instead of
an Intel or Indy CPU means in the real
world it's honestly a give and take but
there are a couple surprises that I
found when using it they absolutely have
to know about if you're considering
buying one the laptop feels almost
weightless in the hand the difference is
definitely noticeable compared to a
MacBook Air it's mostly plastic but the
chassis feels surprisingly rigid and
though it doesn't feel cheap it also
doesn't feel premium we have two USB
type-c ports on the sides and though
there's no speed rating I'm guessing
it's USB 3.1 gen2 on was also able to
connect my 4k display at full resolution
and it did accept the charge through USB
type-c which is great the base model
comes with 256 gigabytes of SSD and also
eight gigabytes of RAM which I'm glad
that Samsung didn't she bowed on we also
have a built-in micro SD card slot that
is designed for long-term storage not
just quickly transferring files that is
great because you can cheaply expand
your laptop in the future
in that same slot we have a SIM card for
LTE web access anywhere that you go but
more on this in just a bit on to the
display after recently using many 16 by
10 and 3 by 2 laptops going back to 16
by 9 is noticeable but if you've been
using wider aspect ratio screens all the
time I think you'll be just fine
vessels are slim though and the 1080p
display looks better than many other
brands I've used because it gets fairly
bright with good contrast and good
viewing angles 1080p doesn't look bad on
a 13-inch display and on the plus side
it sips power compared to a 3 or 4 K
display it's also a touch screen with
good responsiveness but I think because
of the touch screen layer reflectivity
is increased which is the biggest issue
with this and many other Windows laptops
if you're going to be using it outside
do you know that you will have to deal
with some glare above the display we
have a 720p webcam that's fairly good
quality but makes video look darker than
in real life on the plus side the audio
quality
is very good for a laptop Mike here's a
sample of the webcam and microphone
quality I was quite surprised most
microphones that are in laptops like
this really cut out the high frequencies
and this one retains that and it sounds
quite a bit better instead of sounding
muffled the speakers are ported to the
sides so they don't get blocked if it's
on your lap they do sound a bit thin but
are surprisingly loud about three
decibels louder than the MacBook Air go
ahead and take a listen for yourself
[Music]
while it doesn't sound great it actually
beats out some Windows laptops that are
two or three times the size the keyboard
features large backlit chiclet keys but
they have low travel and they feel
slightly mushy in my hands-on comparison
I said that I might choose the MacBook
Airs butterfly keyboard over this one
but after spending many hours typing
including this full review I have to say
that I changed my mind
but that's still not saying that much
the trackpad is also decent it is
plastic but it's fairly easy to click
and though it doesn't match up to say a
surface laptop 3 it is about average for
Windows laptops I do wish it was
slightly taller but it makes sense that
it can be because of how small this
machine is I'm glad that Samsung
included a fingerprint scanner built-in
to the power button but I did notice
having to retry my finger more often
than with other laptops but overall it
does work and I'm glad that it's there
now it's time to talk about the biggest
news here and that is the performance of
the mobile Snapdragon ARM processor it's
an 8 core and wrap performance smokes
Apple's latest MacBook Air but that's a
benchmark and things change in the real
world launching and navigating Windows
10 was fairly smooth overall but it did
get a few hang-ups that required hard
reboots along with this I had issues
connecting external SSDs one would
connect but not show up and the other
would hang up on me when I'm trying to
transfer files I'm guessing that this is
just a software bug because obviously
you shouldn't have this issue and along
with this there was one other big issue
which i think is software related but
I'll mention that in just a bit when
it's relevant all the stock apps worked
as normal which is great but many
third-party apps wouldn't work in fact I
couldn't test out the SSD speeds on this
machine or the display color accuracy
because the apps that I use in the
alternatives that I looked for were not
supported if you want to do things like
photo or video editing or other
intensive productivity tasks do not buy
this laptop that's because most Windows
apps are designed for x86 CPUs from
Intel or AMD and they won't work or
release work well with cell phone
processors like the ARM chip in this
laptop at least for now sure there may
be some apps that are written or
adapted to work and support ARM chips or
even older versions that can run
emulated like the old version of
Photoshop that we tested out with the
surface pro X but the performance is
terrible an iPad with a new Photoshop
app will be a much better experience the
Microsoft Store will actually tell you
to upgrade your device when you select
an app that isn't supported which is
laughable when you just dropped a
thousand dollars on a laptop in 2020 the
most frustrating thing is that I
couldn't find a filter that only showed
arm supported apps which is crazy
considering these types of devices have
been available for multiple years now
and Windows is really focused on arm
this laptop works best with very popular
simpler productivity apps like the
office suite and also web-based tasks so
thankfully Samsung is not targeting the
certain demographic that needs hardcore
apps and power now support for arm is
also slowly rolling out including new
web browsers to offer snappier
performance the default edge browser
performance isn't terrible it's
definitely better than when I first
tested out the surface pro X but you do
notice some lag when maximizing windows
scrubbing through videos and even at
times just typing this is something that
you won't notice with the $600 pixel
book Gogh or Windows laptops I ended up
downloading Firefox as negative arm
support and the performance was so much
snappier so would highly recommend
downloading it or another ARM based
browser even though some mobile ported
games work like asphalt 9 the
performance is terrible
the graphics are technically capable but
I didn't see more than about 50% usage
when playing likely due to poor
optimization so if you want to play
games know that most simply will not
work so if we have so many limitations
with arm then what's the point here are
the three main ones battery life LTE and
heat because of an efficient seven
nanometer design there is no fan at all
so it's completely silent the only time
I felt any heat whatsoever was after
watching 60 FPS 4k HDR video which it
actually played back perfectly smoothly
thanks to dedicated graphics decoding
it looked surprisingly good even then it
wasn't that hot just slightly warm in
one central spot the biggest reason has
got to be the battery life this thing is
rated for a massive 25 hours of video
playback now I'm sure that that's at low
screen brightness but from my experience
with it
for normal use you can reasonably expect
16 to 20 hours of mixed use that is
absolutely crazy being about twice that
what the competition offers in real
world use now even though the battery
life is great I did have a related issue
that is battery drain when I'm not using
it my MacBook could be off for a week
and it loses barely any battery whereas
the Galaxy book s went from 85 percent
down to 25 percent in less than two days
of just being asleep that reminds me
more of smartphones than laptops
I'm not sure if this is a result of the
always-on always ready design the
Microsoft is pushing or something else
the last reason to go arm is the support
for a SIM card so they you can have data
anywhere most laptops don't offer this
and it can be very convenient if you
travel it has a good gigabit modem but I
wasn't able to test it as it only
supports Sprint and Verizon and I have
t-mobile
but speed should be similar to the
higher-end Samsung phones I could
definitely see the galaxy Book s in a
business person's bag or briefcase
taking up almost no room and adding very
little weight and also doing a great job
for email and web use having the freedom
of not having to find Wi-Fi access us
gotta be great and not only because many
hotspots are so slow but also for
security reasons price-wise it's also
very reasonable coming in at lower than
a MacBook Air adult XPS or a surface
laptop three plus the ability to
increase it with microSD you can buy a
good 512 gigabyte microSD card with
fairly reasonable speeds for only $95.00
I'll go ahead and drop a link for you
guys down below this is something that
you can't do with the MacBook Air or
with most Windows laptops even if they
offer a card they were gonna stick way
out which isn't practical for daily
attached storage so now taking an honest
why the overall look at the
machine in most areas like the display
the keyboard the speaker's trackpad
webcam and the general performance of
this galaxy book s it is just good
enough but not really good in anything
but the battery life because of that I
think that if you don't need to stand
out features like battery life and LTE I
would absolutely recommend one of two
Ultrabook laptops that I link down in
the video description below I think that
most people will be happier with those
options and to answer the question in
the title no I don't think the arm is
ready for the masses sure it has gotten
a lot better in the last year but app
selection is still limited and apps are
just starting to be more optimized for
arm
so unless most of your work is web-based
I would wait another year before giving
an arm laptop a chance let me know what
you think down in the comment section
below and click above to subscribe if
you guys want to see my comparison to
the MacBook Air click right over there
this man max the max tech and I will see
you in the next video
[Music]